run i know that they just happened
like women shouldn't like if loyalty
truly matters to you you shouldn't
like date something like you shouldn't
date or marry somebody that's going to
cheat on you if that matters to you but
i don't think that saying oh i have
options i i should be allowed to
exercise my options
is is necessarily healthy
see what i say this look men need to
maintain discipline in order to
safeguard against relationships modern
day relationships however there's a
fundamental difference depending on at
what stage you meet that man in his life
if you allow that man to grow if you see
the ambition
work with him help him develop as a man
and he attains that one percent status
by all means he should give you sexual
exclusivity but if you buy into his
lifestyle you meet him when it's already
made
then you don't deserve that then the
reason being is because
men have to create their value whilst
women are born of value so sex means
something completely different to us so
i think whilst i say many to maintain
discipline it's their choice because
a man
even to have a seat at the sexual
marketplace has to become something so
if you didn't help him become that thing
you can't demand that he be sexually
exclusive to you
well okay so i get i get what you said
but i think
so
yeah so if you if you work your way up
to the one percent
i do feel as though
like yes you may have options and you
can kind of sow your seed but if a woman
is in the one percent as well and you're
dating her but like from what male
standards right not necessarily
financially but physically emotionally
maturity intellectually
would you have a problem would you would
you have a problem with a woman
having a sugar daddy if the sugar daddy
had a vasectomy and you're not worried
about paternity tests
because that would mean that she's not
like she's not content with you
providing and if you're married to a
woman and she's
still having sex with you but you're not
satisfied with that
are we doing this on the condition that
i'm also one percent individual yes
then then of course not why would i
waste my time over i could literally
have almost any woman that i want so why
would you yeah but but it's it's not
easy to replace a one percent woman just
like it's not easy to replace it it kind
of is though for those guys it's not
that hard the new girl turns 22 every
day we're like we're like women like
when are you ever going to be in contact
with the one percent guy again yeah but
it's a very occasion
but realistically though like yeah
they're young fertile beautiful
and some virginal women but
like do you want like a lot of drama
that comes out i'll say this ideally in
the scenario and you said if you do find
a one percent woman
then in respect for when she meets you
then she's a one percenter you should do
what you can to keep her the perspective
i come from is more the realistic aspect
where i can't determine whether you're
that one percent if i was to lose all my
earnings tomorrow would you be there for
me or are you just here for the good
times because i can't determine that
because you haven't been there from the
start you don't deserve my exclusivity
because if my money goes do you go
i would never know so that's exactly
what i was going to get to i think a lot
of people that talk about this on the
internet talking about like oh if i'm a
one percent person i should be allowed
to cheat like a lot of these guys don't
realize because like we've we've been
living in a bull market from 2009 to
present like people don't realize like
money can go very quickly and so if i'm
dating a guy that happens to be in the
one percent and he's cheating on me
while he's making all this money if he
loses it tomorrow
when he was in his prime when he had
options he was cheating on me so what
incentive do i have as a woman to
to really stick around well
i'm staying if i'm not married like and
it's just dating because i i value
marriage a lot but what incentive do i
have to build this man up only for him
to
to sleep around and have sex with other
women and and treat other women when i
was the one that was building that
that's what i said so if you help me
build with it then you absolutely
you deserve my sexual exclusivity but if
you've met me in my prime with all my
money you've just bought into my
lifestyle you just don't get that but if
you but if you didn't have money
realistically you're not going to get
like the like hottest
girl like what what you would
i'm not saying i'm not seeing you i'm
talking i'm referring to a 1
man like let's just say you met in high
school and you fell in love like that
guy on the video
like
oh gosh i don't want to insult him i
mean more like
um
you're probably not going to attract
like a victorious secret model so like
if you were to attain the one percent
wouldn't you kind of look at her being
like um
i don't know i could probably find a
girl that's like better kind of thing i
just say average men
they they aren't afforded the luxury of
cheating so they should absolutely be
faithful i'm just saying once you've
once you've achieved a certain status
then the world is your oyster and that
includes women
so
again if you've built with me then you
have every reason that man i should stay
loyal to you because you're a part of
the reason he was successful if you had
nothing to do with him obtaining his
success then you can't demand
stuff off him like why why you when is
it
like literally i could open my eyes as
women everywhere it doesn't make any
sense logically especially if i want to
fulfill my biological imperative because
what you're asking to do is conform to
your standard which puts me at a
disadvantage yeah but there's there's a
lot of things that i want to do that are
not healthy for me and that would have a
negative effect on society like um well
i'm not i'm not into drugs or anything
but like for me i love sugar so if i
like consumed sugar constantly and i was
spending all my money at bakeries and i
was and i had a and then i ended up
getting a diabetic problem and i ended
up getting heavy like that would that
would be a problem for my health that
would be like a burden on society in
many ways
that doesn't mean just because you want
to do it doesn't mean it's good well
society was society was built on
polygamy actually like every all every
king throughout all of history has had
multiple women so to say it's not
healthy for society when that's how
society was built is just incorrect but
if you love this woman if you genuinely
love her why would you want to put her
through such insecurities such agony why
would you want your sons to look up to
because men men love men love in
different ways yes i understand
forgetting the key thing
what i'm really saying is find your man
young
and stay with him
that's really what i'm saying but your
women are out here sitting on the
sidelines waiting for a guy to blow up
and then say look oh hey here i am you
haven't done nothing to deserve that so
why do you deserve that lifestyle when
i've had to work day and night killing
myself most successful men are like you
don't understand what they have to go
through to attain that level of status
but then to say well i've just come out
of nowhere and now you have to give me
all all of that you have
plus give me your exclusivity it makes
zero sense because you ever had to do
that you haven't had to struggle to
reach that status if you had done it
with him you deserve everything he has
to offer and more but if he didn't do
that with him there's no reason why he
deserved that yeah and i and i
understand but men and women are
different women are kind of born like a
ten or they're born in eight they're
born of four men do have to build
themselves and that's just the common
understanding that that you have is and
then if you're a 10 and you're
submissive and you have some sort of
skill and you're loyal and you're nice
and you're not argumentative like
like men like
historically speaking have worked have
built like have put everything into
their business into their career so that
they could attain a woman like that so
then to say that she's not entitled to
anything i mean no one's entitled to
anything but i think i think the point
is they're never gonna have the same
amount of leverage as a one percent guy
because a new girl turns i mean 22
throughout history 18 whatever it is
every day so you're just you're never
gonna have the same amount of leverage
as a one percent guy i'm not saying it's
right i'm not i'm not putting on my
moral judgment like my dad's a top one
percent guy he didn't cheat on my mom
but like the point is those guys have
the leverage and if they want to do it
they can and a lot of girls are okay
with it yeah they can do it but i think
you should
certainly be clear about it before you
enter again
i agree most even in the red pill most
coaches will say be honest
yeah i mean it it might it may be
difficult to find a woman that would be
willing to do you think oh no a lot of
women a lot of women can i have i have
another thing too because i know a lot
of like guys they're very much in fear
of marriage which i understand because
the divorce courts are very much in
their favor
but like how could you honestly say like
that
they they can cheat
and then
like if i'm married to a guy and he
cheats i if i have kids i i don't know
if i would leave for sure but if he
cheated and got some girl pregnant
like that's grounds for divorce for me
and like if you cheat and you're you're
you're a one percent guy
like she can take you for all of your
money
so like
i just feel like it's kind of leading
men astray in some ways
no i agree with you i think it's a high
risk i don't i don't morally agree with
it but i'm not trying to change like
what the what is the world yeah and like
when you're in certain circles that's
just how it is like wives will shake
side chicks hands
yeah they'll just become sister wives
i also feel like there are sacrifices
that are made on both parties typically
when a man when a man enters a committed
relationship he promises that he won't
have sex with other women and a woman
promises that she won't leave him when a
man with better resources or
is better looking or whatever it is
comes along right but he's talking about
the girls that wait at the finish line
so he's talking about the girls that
just want a guy that has everything like
it's like you're selling a disney fairy
tale when you want a guy that has all of
the things you look for and he's going
to give you monogamy well like he's a
top 1 earner i think that's dicey though
because like from my perspective i'm 20
but i know exactly what i want i want to
live in the mountains i want to have a
strong loving masculine man that shares
my values i've already said this where i
can live in the mountains homeschool my
kids and we just kind of escape from
modern society
but like i i happen to date guys that
are
typically like late 20s early 30s
because they know what they want they
have their life together i'm not